two of the country's largest retailers
are changing their approach to guns in
their stores the recent wake of recent
mass shootings Walmart says it will no
longer sell ammunition for handguns or
for short-barreled rifles the ammo can
be used in assault-style weapons and the
grocery chain Kroger and Walmart are
both asking customers not to openly
carry firearms into stores
Jeff Fergus is outside a Walmart in
Clinton Maryland Jeff why did these
retailers make this move and why now
good morning walmart CEO called the
status quo on guns unacceptable just to
give you a little background in 2015 the
retailer stop selling assault style
rifles well now it's going a step
further and it's sending a message to
the rest of the business world the
pressure was on Walmart to take action
after last month's shooting at a Walmart
store in El Paso Texas in which 22
people were killed it was the deadliest
shooting in the company's history in a
memo to employees Walmart CEO Doug
McMillon called the string of recent
mass shootings a complex situation
lacking a simple solution by changing
its policy he said Walmart is trying to
take constructive steps to reduce the
risk that events like these will happen
again some customers praised the
decision I'm making the changes I really
am everyone because I don't think people
should want innocent people are getting
killed for nothing
while others disagreed you wanna deny
our business I'll take my business
elsewhere the National Rifle Association
called Walmart's decisions shameful and
said that it had succumbed to the
pressure of the anti-gun elites Walmart
is one of many major companies
rethinking its approach to gun sales in
August Kelly Watson filed a lawsuit
against Kroger after her father was shot
and killed in a Louisville Kentucky
store she spoke to CBS this morning
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
last month to think that this man is
loving and as caring as he as he was to
have been taken from us and the
that he was taking because if someone
else's hate is it's unbelievable there
comes after Kroger's decision on Tuesday
Watson told CBS news that she and her
family were pleased with the steps
saying there is no reason for people to
bring guns into grocery stores Walmart
is the biggest private employer in the
United States and serves people all over
the country who hold a range of views on
guns and gun rights David Chapman is
with the Giffords Law Center to Prevent
Gun Violence just like CVS stopping
selling cigarettes walmart has decided
that for their business model and their
customers this makes good business sense
today's Washington Post is running a
full-page editorial calling on Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell to act
but McConnell has made it clear that he
is waiting for the White House to chart
a path forward on gun control
legislation and even after that shooting
in West Texas over the weekend another
mass shooting the president still has
not committed to any specific approach
Tony
until Congress takes action it seems
some corporations will in the meantime
Jeff thank you very much